the bite administration is preparing to
drop
another two trillion dollars into the
economy now however you
feel about the green new deal
reparations bill you got to wonder
what does that do to the economy when
you throw that much money around doesn't
the value of money decline
warren cass is one of the few people who
studies inflation carefully and
understands the risks of it he's
executive director at american compass
he joins us tonight warren thanks so
much for coming on
leaving aside the merits or demerits of
the actual bill
when you dump this much money into the
system what are the risks of it
well there are a lot of risks tucker one
as as you mentioned is you just get
inflation prices of everything
just goes up i think what we've been
seeing recently
and is probably the biggest risk is that
the money just all
ends up on wall street and you see it
going into private equity and hedge
funds and rising stock prices and
cryptocurrency
and this sort of just inflation of of
assets that that really only benefits
the
the wealthy segment of americans
so the income inequality which
conservatives including me ignored for a
long time clearly it's real clearly it's
driving a lot of the social pathologies
that we're all so distressed about
this is the primary driver of that it
seems like fed policy dumping
all this money most of which gets
captured by wall street
i think that's exactly right we've just
published research at american compass
that looks at how much money is flowing
out of the real economy and on to wall
street and that's coming both from
companies that are just doing buybacks
and dividends instead of making
investments
and then it's also coming as you said
from from the government that just keeps
pumping more money into the economy and
and you see that in things like
you know the stock market being just
completely disconnected from
from the real economy you know it's
during a pandemic year it practically
doubled
uh you see it in cryptocurrency you see
it in all these places and then at the
end of the day you look at
at where's the wealth in this country
and you find over the past 30 years the
the top 10 of wealthiest households we
found gained
28 trillion dollars of wealth and the
bottom 50 percent gained
nothing and that's that's that's what
you get when all the money goes into
assets and and only some people hold the
assets
it there is this set you can kind of
feel it people are behaving as if money
isn't real
that is not a good sign like in a
functioning economy
people understand the connection between
money and value but that seems to have
been severed or am i just imagining it
no i think that's exactly right and and
in my mind it's especially important
when we talk about investment
which you know is one of these words
that that just gets thrown around a lot
and we call everything investment and
everybody's an investor now
but but real investment means actually
putting
resources to work having people build
things creating new capacity
most of what's going on you know if you
think about wall street and all of the
trading and the speculation
that's that's not investment that's
that's just speculating it doesn't
actually
build anything and so i think we have a
real problem in this country where
people have found it's more profitable
to just kind of trade things around in a
circle
in a lot of cases than it is to to go
and build something
and and we see the results in in how
things have played out in the economy
where
you know we've seen wages not rising
productivity doesn't rise
we see ourselves losing competitively
against china
and then you turn around in wall street
and look at wall street and things have
never been better that's such a good
point it's so nice to hear someone say
it out loud oren cass thank you
thank you